I have here in my hands project shield a
new android device from nvidia which is
designed around gaming now can do
everything that android can do it runs
jellybean the idea here is to focus on
android games as well as streaming pc
games from of course your pc now in
order to do that your PC does have to
have in videos later d force gtx
processor but if you got that enabled
you can stream PC games from anywhere in
your home if you're doing that at home
you're not gonna be able to use your pc
for other things but it does run steam
and you can connect it to your TV and
basically play any pc game on your TV as
well using hdmi now when you're going
out on the road you're only be able to
play android games but that's not a bad
deal at all because there's a 720p
5-inch display on this unit here runs
full android clay anything from google
play and NVIDIA zone TegraZone store
it's pretty slick we don't know how much
it's going to cost but it should arrive
in q2 sometime this year